clothes for Puerto Rico's governor to
step down are intensifying today after
what appeared to be the largest protest
on the island in decades overnight
thousands gathered outside governor
Ricardo Russo's mansion and called for
him to resign immediately the
demonstrations turned violent as
protesters clashed with police
many ran when the tear gas was fired
into the crowd
David beg no was in the middle of the
protest last night and joins us now with
the latest on this story from San Juan
David have you heard have you heard any
word on how long we can expect these
protests to continue no we haven't but I
have asked protesters if they're getting
tired and they say not at all in fact
every time the governor gives an
interview like he did yesterday with Fox
it adds fuel to their fire it was a wild
and chaotic night let me walk you
through it so you got broken glass this
is the scene in many parts of San Juan
there's new graffiti on the street
excuse us sir if you look at this
vehicle this is the car that caught fire
last night Canton show the viewers if
you can that's the tear gas canister
right there that led the back of this
car to burn in fact on the ground this
morning you can see some more of the
canisters fired by police this man
Robbie is the gentleman whose car the
car belongs to him he had been
participating in the protests yesterday
during the day but he was with a friend
last night when police fired tear gas
and protesters and one of the canisters
landed in his vehicle here's that video
it happened right around midnight
you see from about 50 yards away that
teargas canister come flying through the
air and right into the back of that SUV
tear gas was first deployed by police
around 11:00 p.m. and that sent
protesters running the puerto rico
police department resorted to force
after plastic water bottles were
continuously thrown at them but just a
few troublemakers ended up ruining the
night for a majority of peaceful people
we spoke to Elliot Rivero
about why he's here protest no parties
no colors just pata Rica
fighting for our right we noticed that
the front line is filled with very young
faces some as young as 15 Kunia Nunez is
21 tell me why you're here
[Music]
hundreds of thousands of demonstrators
kicked off the week by shutting down a
major highway and the crowd size was
massive Puerto Ricans are frustrated
about corruption the debt crisis and a
slow recovery following Hurricane Maria
they're all so upset about leaked chat
messages where the governor and some of
his associates made sexist and
homophobic remarks and mocked
constituents including those who died
during hurricane Maria I've seen the
protests on Monday the governor
apologized for the chat language on Fox
News he said he was not going to run for
re-election in 2020 but he also made
clear he still has no plans to resign
we've made policy changes that are
significant for for women for LGBTQ
everything that that was said I assume
responsibility for I apologized his
refusal to leave has made popular Puerto
Ricans like Presidente dumbfounded and
furious this is the first time that for
the Ricans resign
we have to something about it Presidente
is a popular rapper who literally has
been on the front lines leading people
to continue protests daily Puerto Rico
police have just arrived to take
pictures of the vehicle that burned last
night after police fired tear gas into
the back of it Tony I should tell you
yesterday in that Fox News interview
that ricardo rosado gave to shepherd
smith Shep asked him who on the island
supports you and he kind of fumbled and
couldn't name anybody and then he said
the mayor of San Sebastiano
we called the mayor of San Sebastiano
and the mayor told CBS News he does not
support the governor Wow David and so
the answer appears to be no support no
official support anyway at this moment
incredible footage there and incredible
reporting for us David Magnum in Puerto
Rico David thank you very much